Turn with me in your Bibles to one Samuel Chapter 19,
one Samuel Chapter 19.
And stand with me if you're able
for the reading of God's word.
I
And Saul spoke to Jonathan, his son,
and to all his servants that they should kill David.
But Jonathan Saul's son delighted much in David
and Jonathan told David, Saul, my father seeks to kill you.
And Jonathan told David, Saul, uh,
therefore be on your guard in the morning.
Stay in a secret place and hide yourself.
And I'll go out and stand beside my father in the field
where you are, and I'll speak to my father about you.
And if I learn anything, I'll tell you.
And Jonathan spoke well of David to Saul, his father,
and said to him, let not the king sin
against his servant David.
'cause he has not sinned against you.
And because his deeds have brought good to you
for he took his life in his hand
and he struck down the Philistine.
And the Lord worked a great salvation for all Israel.
You saw it and rejoiced,
why then will you sin against innocent blood
by killing David without cause?
And Saul listened to the voice of Jonathan, Saul swore
as the Lord lives he shall not be put to death.
And Jonathan called David
and Jonathan reported to him all these things.
And Jonathan brought David to Saul
and he was in his presence as
before and there was war again.
And David went out and fought with the Philistines
and struck them with a great blow so
that they fled before him.
Then a harmful spirit from the Lord came upon Saul
as he sat in his house with his spear in his hand.
And David was playing the liar.
And Saul sought to pin David to the wall with the spear.
But he alluded Saul so
that he struck the spear into the wall and David fled
and escaped that night.
Saul sent, sent messengers to David's house to watch him
that he might kill him in the morning.
But Nicole, David's wife told him, if you do not escape
with your life tonight, tomorrow you will be killed.
So we call, let David down through the window
and he fled away and escaped.
We call, took an image and laid it on the bed
and put it, put a pillow of goat's hair at its head
and covered it with his clothes.
And when Saul sent messengers to take David,
he said he is sick.
And Saul sent the messengers to see David saying,
bring him up to me in the bed that I may kill him.
And when the messengers came in,
behold the image was in the bed with the pillow
of goat's hair at its head.
Saul said to McCall, why have you deceived me thus
and let my enemy go so that he has escaped?
And McCall answered Saul, he said to me, let me go.
Why should I kill you?
Now David fled and escaped and he came to Samuel at Rama
and told him all that Saul had done to him.
And he and Samuel went and lived at,
and it was told Saul, behold David, uh, is at Naau in Rama.
Then Saul sent messengers to take David.
And when they saw the company of the prophets prophesying
and Samuel standing his head over them, the spirit
of God came upon the messengers of Saul.
And they also prophesied when it was told Saul,
he sent other messengers and they also prophesied.
And Saul sent messengers again a third time,
and they also prophesied.
Then he himself went to Rama
and came to the great well that is in Siku.
And he asked, where are Samuel and David?
And one said, behold they're at auth and Rama.
And he went there to, to auth in Rama.
And the spirit of God came upon him also.
And as he went, he prophesied until he came to Nath in Rama.
And he too stripped off his clothes and he too prophesied
before Samuel and lay naked all that day and all that night.
Thus it is said, is Saul also among the prophets?
That is the word of the Lord. And you may be seated.
Thank you. Good morning everyone.
It's great to see you on a cold morning
and I'm grateful to God for the warmth we have in here.
Amen. And really, I feel like I'm at home.
Here's a, here's a fun fact.
The the rug that I'm standing on
was in our house in our living room for about a decade.
And so it feels like home. Our, uh, our kids.
We have four kids and they all
grew up playing on this very rug.
Our, our little Noel rolled around as a baby on this rug.
So it's a special thing for me to be up here right now.
I'm grateful to be able to open the Bible
with you this morning as we continue
our study of one Samuel.
My name is Ryan and it's a real joy to be able to serve
as one of your elders here.
Thank you. In the spring of 1940,
the Nazi war machine had
driven over 300,000 allied soldiers
to the very edge of Europe,
trapping them on the beaches of Dunkirk,
blocked in they were facing capture or destruction.
At any moment it seemed like all hope was lost.
They were sitting ducks.
The vast seemingly unstoppable German army were closing in
and the British expeditionary forces were struggling.
They were on the verge of collapse.
Then a desperate call went out across the English channel
and hundreds of vessels, lifeboats,
merchant ships, pleasure boats, fishing boats,
all joined the struggling royal Navy.
And for days this ragtag fleet of vessels braved
treacherous waters, dodging near constant barrage
of enemy fire.
Yet inexplicably Hitler had ordered his armored
divisions to halt, giving some amount
of relief here.
And also incredibly a dense fog rolled in,
casting an immense shadow over the soldiers, hiding them
from the deadly error attacks from the loft vfa.
And what's more the normally turbulent sea became
as glass.
And then for nine long days the miracle unfolded
over 338,000 soldiers
were rescued from the jaws of defeat.
And Winston Churchill himself declared this to be a
deliverance, a miracle of deliverance.
And so today we're picking up at one Samuel 19
where King Saul's paranoia explodes
and David becomes the target of
multiple attempts on his life.
And in the end,
every attempt ends in a miracle of deliverance.
Why? Because God protects his anointed ones.
And that's the main line of this text this morning
that God protects his anointed ones.
John showed us last week from chapter 18
how Saul's jealousy had led him to hurl spears
and to engineer military traps to try and kill David.
And here in chapter 19, the hostility toward David
has moved from covert to overt.
His hatred of David is out in the open. It's plain to see.
We will study four episodes this morning,
each spotlighting a fresh attempt on David's life.
Hang around you won't believe episode four.
Then we'll close with three points
of application this morning.
But before we begin, let's pray we need it.
Father, your word enlightens our eyes.
Holy Spirit shine light on your word this morning so
that we might glorify Christ and enjoy him more fully
and it's in Christ and we pray.
Amen. So in verse one,
episode one starts,
and we'll call this episode the one where Jonathan talks,
Saul down the one where Jonathan talks, Saul down
and we open with Saul instructing Jonathan
and his servants to kill David.
So there's no more subtlety here.
Saul is done concealing his hatred of David.
And you can imagine Saul throwing a map down
and really enjoying this time, plotting
and scheming against David yet.
And yet Jonathan delighted much in David.
It says, and you'll remember that Jonathan is Saul's son,
but he loves David and he understands
and sees that he is God's chosen.
And Jonathan is yielding his own claim to the throne here.
So when it seems like David's stuck in second gear
and when it hasn't been his day, his week, his month,
or even his year, Jonathan is there for him, right?
So Jonathan warns David in verse two.
Saul, my father seeks to kill you.
Then Jonathan courageously speaks
to Saul on David's behalf in verse four,
let not the the king sin against the servant David.
And take note there, Jonathan is appealing
to his dad's kingship
and he's calling out sin for what it is.
It's sin what sin?
Well we see in Deuteronomy 1910, this is the sin of shedding
innocent blood.
In verse five, Jonathan Hermine saw
how David risked his life going up against Goliath
and how the Lord worked a great salvation for all Israel.
It says, in other words,
why would you kill the man
who brought you such great benefit?
And to all the nation it doesn't make sense.
Surprisingly, Saul relent momentarily.
And notice that I don't say repent.
Saul swears in verse six, as the Lord lives
he shall not be put to death.
So David returns to the palace as
before it says, But you can feel the tension here.
Has Saul truly changed?
The truth is that this vow that David won't die
rings hollow if the inner envy remains still,
God protects his anointed ones this time
through Jonathan's well chosen words and the credits roll.
And that's episode one. Episode two.
We'll call this the one where the spear sends David running
for a long time, one where the spear sends David running
for a long time and we shift scenes.
Verse eight, we see that David fights the Philistines again
and wins handily again.
And that melody
of the old refrained slain Saul has slain his thousands.
But David, his 10 thousands is likely floating
around there in the background.
And so Saul Stews
in dark jealousy verse five says
that a harmful spirit from the Lord torments him.
What is this harmful spirit?
This harmful spirit can be seen
as God's judgment against Saul for opposing God.
This isn't the Holy Spirit.
One commentary frames Saul's frame of mind like this
that his fear and his jealousy ran so deep
that he couldn't even sit in his house without his hand
clutching a spear.
So David is just being David, he's playing his harp.
And then out of nowhere, Saul hurls a spear at him.
Verse 10, he sought to pin David to the wall,
David Dodges and the sear the spear sinks
into splintering wood.
David flees at night never again
to live in Saul's house again.
So no matter Saul's rage, God upholds David.
And you don't see this immediately in the text,
but this is significant.
Don't miss this. This is where
the story really shifts gears here from here on out,
David is a fugitive.
So this is chapter 19.
He's on the run all the way through chapter 30,
and it only really ends here.
Spoiler alert, close your ears
if you don't want to hear this yet.
But it only really ends when Saul is killed in battle
with the Philistines in chapter 31.
But as we'll see that this was a decade long ultra marathon,
doesn't mean that God's plan was faltering in any way.
And he might be wondering, why doesn't God just remove Saul
and put David up as king instead of this 10 year runaround?
That's a good question. Scripture repeatedly shows
that God refines his people through hardships.
And this extended wilderness time for David
becomes like his crucible, forging him
in humility and dependence
and readiness to shepherd God's people.
Check this out. Psalm 63, you can feel his hunger
for God and see his humility.
Oh God, you are my God.
Earnestly I seek you my soul thirsts for you.
My flesh faints for you and it as in a dry
and weary land where there is no water.
So I've looked upon you in a sanctuary beholding your power
and glory because your steadfast love is
better than life.
My lips will praise you, so I will bless you
as long as I live in your name.
I will lift up my hands.
So good. This is a heart
refined in the desert.
This is God making a man of God.
God refines his people in the desert.
This anchor of truth remains.
God protects his anointed ones.
Saul Spear has sent David running for a long, long
time and the credits roll
and that's episode two.
Now we come to episode three, we'll call this one the one
with fake David, the one with fake David.
And we open in the darkness outside David's house.
It's in verse 11 that we see that Saul sends messengers
to watch the door planning to kill David at dawn.
But me call David's wife. You remember Saul's daughter?
She warns David, if you do not escape
with your life tonight, tomorrow
you will be killed.
And we read that in verse 12.
So we call let David down through the window
and he fled away and escaped.
And this reminds us of other window escapes in scripture,
doesn't it, Paul in Damascus and then Rahab
and the spies in Jericho.
And once David's gone, McCall puts a dummy in the bed,
she puts an Ile, a household image.
The Hebrew here is Phim in the bed.
She covers it with clothes, places,
goat's, hair by the head.
And so let's pause here for just a second.
Why is there an idol in David's house? It's a good question.
Well, it probably not.
David's, it seems as if
David is unequally yoked here with Bal.
Bal doesn't appear to be a follower of God.
And when the assassins appear, she says in verse 14,
he's sick, Saul is furious
and he orders them
to bring David in bed if necessary to kill him.
But they uncover the deception.
In verse 16, the image was in the bed.
Saul confronts his daughter who deflects blame
and lies saying that David
threatened to kill her.
Such a relatable story. We've all been there, right?
We've been there. Our father-in-law who also happens
to be our boss, hates us, decides, you know what,
I'm done with that guy.
Let's kill him. You know,
you've probably experienced that before.
And then our wife, she helps us escape out the window.
She just kinda lowers us down
and then puts a statue in the bed, covers it
with goat hair and clothes.
And then the guys, the the murder squad who come
to try and take us out.
They, uh, you know, she, she goes to the door, she's like,
oh, he can't come out.
You know, you, you've understand this, right?
This is a relatable story.
This is something that we've all experienced. All right?
All right. Maybe that's not exactly true.
We haven't experienced this thing, but stay with me here.
Psalm 59 is connected to this story.
Bible headings aren't the inspired word of God,
but some headings note that David
wrote Psalm 59 when Saul sent men
and they watched the house.
By the way, our very young Brent McCoy preached excellently
on the psalm two summers ago.
So check that out while we don't face assassins at dawn,
what we do relate to is the emotion
that David is feeling in this moment.
And I want you to feel this too in verse one of Psalm 59,
David, pray, deliver me for my enemies.
Oh my God. And this captures the desperation of
that night For all the cunning
watchers that are outside.
David knows that real deliverance has to come from the Lord.
Same psalm verse nine oh my strength.
I will watch for you, for you, oh God are my fortress.
David's desperate here.
Are You desperate right now in something?
If so, mirror David here where he cries out.
He said, oh my strength, I will watch for you,
for you, oh God are my fortress.
This fortresslike protection plays out in real time here.
God uses Nicole's deception to protect David
and to ensure that he remains free.
And to be clear, this isn't some endorsement of lying.
So don't get hung up on that.
We see more of David's heart that night.
Psalm 59 16 reveals, I will sing aloud
of your steadfast love in the morning.
And that is David repeating a biblical truth
that we see in scripture.
David also writes in a different psalm, Psalm 30 verse five,
where he says, weeping may linger for the night,
but joy comes when with the morning.
Joy comes with the morning.
So now my heart isn't to minimize any, any pain
that you may be in right now,
but we're assured this in scripture
suffering is temporary
and joy is guaranteed
ultimately back to the text.
Instead of being killed.
At dawn, David writes about singing to the Lord, testifying
to God's faithfulness.
So episode three ends with me,
call outsmarting Saul's man while David runs for his life.
And with Saul standing furious
that he has been thwarted again.
The main point remains. God protects his anointed ones.
And that is episode three.
So now we come to episode four,
it's the finale in the series.
I'm sad to say we'll call this one the one
where God's spirit turns killers into choir members,
killers into choir members.
Verse 18 shows us
that David flees aama about three miles away.
David confides in Samuel
and the prophet who had anointed him, if you remember.
And they stay at auth. The word auth means dwelling.
So this is likely a place where prophets live.
Shepherds lived a camp of sorts
and these dwellings are within rama.
So Saul learns of David's hideout in verse 19
and then sends messengers once more.
And unlike other episodes where God uses people
to accomplish his purposes, this one is unique.
This time God intervenes directly
and supernaturally.
So as soon as Saul's messengers arrived, verse 20 says
that the spirit of God came upon the messengers of Saul
and he also prophesied.
They can't seize David
because the Holy Spirit has overwhelmed them.
And Saul's messengers can't help
but join this worship service that's happening.
So it says they prophesied, prophesied doesn't always mean,
uh, predicting the future.
What it can mean is, uh, speaking words from God,
worshiping God, praying to him, singing even.
And so these killers have been turned into choir members.
The second wave of messengers comes same outcome.
Join the choir. Third wave messengers comes. Same thing.
Join the choir. So Saul says, I, I need to do this myself.
Then goes to Rama, ask for directions, continues on.
Then verse 23, the spirit of God came upon him also.
And as he went, he prophesied
and in a scene that's astonishing
and humiliating, verse 24 says, he stripped off his clothes
and he too prophesied before Samuel
and lay naked all that day, all that night.
Now this could mean that he, uh,
became fully unclothed,
but more than likely it's just his royal robe,
his royal garments.
So Saul, he was once so sure of himself, he lies disrobed,
helpless before God's prophet powerless
to do a thing about David.
He's totally humiliated here.
It's as if God can't even stand to have
Saul dressed as king in his presence.
And the text ends on this rhetorical note, is Saul also
among the prophets echoing one Samuel 10.
But now there's a little bit of tragic irony here.
The point here is that he is not truly among the prophets.
So ends our finale, the camera zooms out.
Saul is in disarray.
He is physically humiliated, morally undone.
David is unscathed.
So after four attempts, Saul remains empty handed.
And that main point blasts like a trumpet call.
One more time. God protects his anointed ones.
He can do it through wise friends.
He can do it through quick reflexes, through hairy dummies.
And he can do it through the power of the spirit of God.
None can stand against God's chosen.
So what do we do with these four episodes?
What is the application for us?
Well, it's tempting to stop
and say, well, you know, so what?
We don't have a literal Saul chasing us with a spear.
8.1 billion people.
Maybe there's one or two people, maybe one
or two literal Sas chasing people around with spears.
Let's say 10 tend to be safe,
10 literal Sauls chasing people around with spears.
But for us who don't have literal Saul chasing us,
what is the application?
What we do have the same God that David did.
And uh, it says in James one 17 that
with God there is no variation or shadow due to change.
He does not change ever.
And we also have an even greater anointed one than David,
Jesus the king.
And what do we do with that? That we have the same God
and we have an even greater king than David.
Three points to bring it home.
First, don't oppose to lord's anointed.
Don't oppose the Lord's anointed. That's right.
Don't follow Saul's footsteps
by rejecting the rightful king.
Saul clung to his throne
even though God had chosen David.
And sometimes we do the same.
We dig in our heels against Christ's authority
and that rebellion, it can be subtle.
We may talk a good game about Jesus,
but we haven't given over everything in our life to him,
our our lips honor him, but our hearts are far from him.
Scripture says, and it's like we,
we insist on deciding our morals
or our identity all on our own terms,
whether it's in finances or sexuality or relationships,
or maybe the rebellion is seen as
how we disregard the the value
and the dignity of human life.
Saul's refusal to yield is basically our refusal
to yield to Jesus every area of our life.
It's been said that our arms are too short to box with God.
And if we do try to box with him, we face the same futility
that left Saul humiliated, stripped of control.
So the call is simple, but it's urgent.
Yield the throne to Jesus,
don't oppose the Lord's anointed second
rest confidently in God's protection,
rest confidently in God's protection.
And this point is a lot more comforting
than that one, isn't it?
So we just said that our arms aren't
too short to box with God.
But the greater truth than that is
what we see in Isaiah 59, 1 where it says, behold
the Lord's hand is not shortened, that it cannot save.
Meaning his arms aren't too short to save you,
no matter your past or your predicament.
And we see that in this passage, don't we?
God's arms weren't too short that he couldn't save.
David, be encouraged by that.
Notice also in this, that David's protection isn't passive.
He doesn't just sit around and wait for God to rescue him.
No, he flees. He he hides.
He accepts help from other people.
And yet behind all of these human actions, we see
God's sovereign hand at work, don't we?
And that raises an important question for us.
How do we balance taking responsibility for our own safety
and wellbeing with while trusting in God's
providential care for us?
So our passage suggests
that these two things aren't necessarily mutually exclusive.
We are called to be wise and to take action,
but always with the recognition that
ultimate security comes from the Lord.
Proverbs 2131 says, the horse is made ready for the day
of battle, but victory belongs to the Lord.
So even if we face severe trials, God can use ordinary means
episodes one through three
or extraordinary means episode four, to
preserve us.
And you might be right in the middle of a particular pain.
And you're wondering,
this doesn't feel like God is protecting us.
I get it. The weeping lingers
in the dark of the night continues to cover us,
but believer clinging to his word when it testifies this.
And we know, we know that for those
who love God, all things work together for good, for those
who are called according to his purpose.
Romans 8 28 says,
remember the joy that's guaranteed
to come in the morning.
Ultimately in a similar way
that God protected David his anointed,
we too are anointed through the Holy Spirit.
One John two 20 says, as anointed ones, even if
storms battle battle us financially, relationally,
emotionally, our life is secure in Christ.
Colossians three, three says that our life is hidden
with Christ in God.
Rest confidently in God's protection believer
last look ultimately to Christ.
Look ultimately to Christ.
Let David's story point you to the greater David Jesus.
Now what do I mean by greater David? What does that mean?
David is a man after God's own heart clearly,
but his life was pockmarked with success
and with failure, with righteousness
and with sin and the re.
And this reality is that David was a foreshadowing
of the Messiah.
Jesus who lived a perfect life.
Saul trying to kill David echoes
how religious leaders were trying to kill Jesus.
But just as David's destiny couldn't be thwarted,
neither could Christ.
Amen. In for sure their greatest attempt
crucifying him precisely unfolded God's
redemptive plan, culminating in his resurrection
where David was vindicated through survival.
Jesus is vindicated on an eternal scale,
reigning at God's right hand forever.
Ephesians one says, so how do we respond?
We don't just mimic David's escapes.
Here we surrender to Jesus as king.
And if we do, Romans 8 38 assures us that nothing
can separate us from the love of God in Christ Jesus.
So church, what do we know?
Don't oppose the Lord's anointed,
rest in God's protection and look ultimately to Christ.
So as we come to a close, remember the story of
Dunkirk and recall the dense fog
rolling in where the fog covers
and casts hundreds of thousands of
soldiers in immense shadow.
In a similar way, Psalm 91 speaks of the shadow
of the Almighty.
Verse one proclaims that whoever abides
or stays in the shadow of the almighty stands
protected UNT unassailable.
What about David in this chapter,
whether it was watchers at the door
or spears in the palace, David Abided in the shadow
of the Almighty, do you
stand in the shadow of the Almighty
for you and for me, if we belong to Christ,
we too stand in God's protective shadow.
If you sense that you're resisting
or rejecting Jesus as king,
or you're clinging to a throne that you can't keep
hear God's invitation to repent
and believe, surrender the illusions of control
and bow before him.
Why? Because God protects his
anointed ones.
And in the words of Psalm 91, 1 through two, we can leave
saying He who dwells in the shelter
of the most high will abide in the shadow
of the Almighty.
And I'll say to the Lord, my refuge
and my fortress in God, in whom I
trust.